three questions they do somewhat
increase in difficulty depending on the
way you look at it first we begin we're
in what shapes this again strictly
speaking I actually haven't told you
what it is but I think most people have
inferred what I meant which is the
square what else could it be
it could be well I suppose all squares
are rectangles because if you've got a
square you've got all of the right
angles in the corner so that's also a
rectangle but um it's actually something
else it could be I mean it could be a
rhombus now I know I've sort of drawn it
so everything is nice and neat which is
what I intended but I suppose you can
have one two three four sides that are
all the same but if I like leaned this
over a little bit yeah it could still
have all those equal mates you have the
same perimeter but you're very much
change maybe okay 24 centimeters do we
agree with that as a primitive yeah
thumbs up cuz you go to 6 centimeters 1
2 3 4 times and what is this come from
what's that about 6 times 6 because the
area of a square is the best because
it's just the thing square since it is a
square draw ok number 2 now just before
we are just with what we look at this on
so I want to point out that oh yeah and
I don't I looked at some people's books
as well and now that common answer is
this one now let's just think about that
for a second because it's not a
ridiculous answer it actually does come
from somewhere very common sense where
is this number come from
have a look carefully yeah ok you get 5
by 13 gives you 65 but we know that the
area of a triangle is 1/2 base times
height right so that's half of 65 ok
except the area is not this it is 30 so
why is it 30 and not 13.5 right
yeah very good
it's the hypotenuse opposite the right
angle it's off at an angle right what we
want is this height over here
it's especially it's the perpendicular
height because it's at a right angle
okay how did you find what this link was
in this Pythagoras five twelve thirteen
is what you get and five times 12 is 60
so you haunted what this one where does
that come from
yeah it's just you're adding them right
five twelve thirteen does give you which
by the way to be weird isn't it
why is that just a funny coincidence how
many shapes have the same value for both
of them that's that was completely
intentional Rome absolutely not an
accident no okay let's go into the last
one number three the perimeter of 44
where did that come from we've had a
look at these forms of glass little bit
someone who hasn't said anything yeah
yeah okay so let's rewind a little bit
I'll come to that question before we get
to how we laid this out right where this
come from
is 2pi odd we have a special name for
the perimeter of a circle you remember
what it is it's the sitcom prince very
good okay you multiply the true what
does your calculator stay like now
I did ask you for one decimal place so
you do round this up to 44 however I did
that four bucks I give it to you but I
want all of you to know if you're
answering to one decimal place and
you've rounded and the decimal place
happens to be zero
you should include it because forty four
point zero means actually I I know that
there's more accuracy
know what that decimal place is as
opposed to if I came to de Santa I don't
know if it could be 44 point 1 or 2 or 3
or 4 that all round down to 44 but you
actually know it's 44.0 area have a girl
comes up on that number yes
one hundred fifty point nine meters
squared we've got the unit's right great
job you can read that off